[Applause]
this movie is all about like embracing
your imperfections and figuring out how
they're actually beautiful parts of
yourself how do you do that when you
wake up and you're like okay I gotta be
Nick Jonas today but I'm not feeling
like it you know I haven't grown up in
the public eye and having experienced my
awkward years in the public eye you get
really used to shake things off and
understanding that your imperfections
make you who you are and connect us all
in a big way I think that was one of the
messages in this movie I connected with
the most was just this thought to bring
this message to the fans about
self-acceptance and self-love and also
the love of others and accepting them
and I think it's a particularly poignant
message right now I think everybody
needs to hear this message not just the
kiddos cuz that's adults are the ones
who screw everything up by the way you
look great today
you look good the fashions on point so
I'm wondering cuz you only have a week
left have you got your Met Gala outfit
together
it's come together is it coming together
yeah it's coming together I to be honest
like I'm very excited I love to make out
so it was a fun night but you know
Priyanka will set the tone and I'm just
gonna be there to support so I keep it
simple at her shine that's a good hubby
you found the secret already this
quickly into the marriage you know happy
wife happy life yeah exactly
it is a full circle moment for you guys
though to be on the committee together
how does that feeling to kind of you
know have it come back to that place
it's pretty cool I mean I hope I get
like a clipboard with the names and I
can make sure everyone's on the list and
things like that I don't know what my
responsibilities actually are but I'm
really thrilled they asked us to do that
and it is full circle for us and it'll
just be a fun night it's always a good
time you are a super fan of Game of
Thrones that's a good another good thing
for the family but are you ready for it
to be over like are you good I am not
really ready I mean but all great things
must come to it
and you know the thing that I think is
so great about this show is the bold
approach to say actually we are gonna be
done after this many seasons and we're
not gonna overextend I think that was
really commendable because it's easier
to just keep things going maybe they go
too long but this feels like the right
move
[Music]